but the foul trouble is going to prevent  him from doing that at least for a  little while marketing stuck his hand  and i think that pass  was headed for kevin love  here is irving on the drive and his  easiest basket of the night  make it 11 for 11. jay-z says keep it  going  and starting to get whatever he wants on  the offensive end  kyrie finds durant  that was good a three-pointer for kevin  durant  timeout cleveland  [Applause]  same play cut off once again  now durant rises up cash money kevin  durant  kick  does cleveland have an answer down the  stretch  durant going to work rises up again and  that one's good  back-to-back possessions  timeout cleveland  [Applause]